it's a good thing Charlie Hunnam didn't
play Christian Grey turns out there's
one thing the Sons of Anarchy alum and
triple frontier star can't stand to do
as part of his job and it's the one
thing many others might enjoy the most
Charlie Hunnam hates filming love scenes
in a 20-17 interview with el Hunnam
explained that making out with women on
camera isn't only a lot less glamorous
than it appears to be but it's also kind
of terrifying due in part to the fact
that he's a huge germaphobe the actor
told the publication I've been
profoundly germaphobic since I was a
young child Hunnam shared with el that
his germophobia began when he was only 8
or 9 years old after having learned
about a parasite that caused blindness
he explained there was a parasite from
dogs in the north of England that if you
ingested it can turn you blind we had a
thing in schools to educate the kids
about the importance of hygiene
specifically around dogs because we had
a few kids who went blind that horrified
me as an adult the actor has had a
difficult time getting intimate on
screen you'd think that would be the
best part of the job right ya know I
wake up in cold sweats that's a but
Hannam germophobia is only part of the
reason why he hates shooting love scenes
he's also keenly aware of the effect his
job as a leading man has on his jewelry
designer girlfriend Morgana McNeill Asst
he told el I'm in a very committed
relationship and I'm also cognizant that
it's not my girlfriend's favorite part
of my job
so when Hunnam is forced to feign
intimacy he does so knowing that there's
a fine line he'll have to walk part of
being an actor is making a scene
believable which means that he has to
make a real connection with the person
that he's working with but as he
explained to el it's also important that
it's clear that any onset intimacy is
entirely fabricated and won't spill over
into the real world Hunnam said I try to
be sensitive to the fact that we're
doing something intimate but also keep a
clear boundary it's a delicate balance
to strike to be emotionally open enough
to have an experience that feels honest
between two people but also maintain
that it's just for the film it's not my
favorite thing to do I don't want to
kiss anyone but my girlfriend for my
whole life
fortunately Hunnam has never felt
objectified by others in the industry
and has evidently had an easy enough
time getting people to respect his
feelings and understand where he's
coming from regarding love scenes when
asked if he felt more like an object to
ogle than a living breathing person he
said I don't view myself that way I
obviously am cognizant of the fact that
being handsome gives me greater breadth
of opportunity I'd hope that what I
bring to the table force surpasses just
being handsome so all things considered
it's probably for the best that the
actor wound up dropping out of the first
fifty Shades of Grey film back in 2015
Hunnam had cited scheduling conflicts as
the reason for his departure he had
already promised to be in crimson peak
but perhaps coming to terms with the
full extent of Fifty Shades of Grey's
romantic content had something to do
with pushing him in that direction
either way hana maintains that having to
let go of plain grey was a huge
disappointment for him especially since
he had bonded with the film's director
Sam taylor-johnson he told Elle that was
a somewhat traumatic experience for me I
didn't want to open that wound call it
germophobia or call it true love and an
undying commitment to his girlfriend
whatever the reasoning Charlie Hunnam
will likely never be an actor who loves
stripping down with his co-stars as he
explained the point is everyone thinks
it's great to be an actor and get to
kiss a bunch of beautiful actresses and
films but I actually hate it I wouldn't
even use my goal on Sue's bus that's
just nice thing check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stars
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]